first of all the shoes crazy this is a
very like i couldn't even wrap my head
around what it would take to like
create a shoe yeah how hard is that like
do you have to go find like
manufacturers yeah like are they coming
from asia like
actually they are it says made in china
yeah so china so my boy was a close
friend to me he used to work at lrg he
called me and said his family he ain't
gonna say his name cause they everybody
tried to take your plug so he called me
it was like my family do shoes
they'll be out here do you want to do a
shoot you always used to talk about you
want to do a shoe you have a design i
had this design five years ago okay and
i'm like um we sat down we had a meeting
and we put the whole play together
and i sent him my first idea my first
idea basically was like
i want to do
a fashionable
i want to do a fashionable shoe a chuck
but something to my culture
like a dior like a chuck you know what i
mean i want to put them both together
that's why you got the big
the big top that's why you don't have
the black thing right here that's why
you got the ugg
kind of feel in the inside it's so
comfortable on the inside you know what
i'm saying so i damn near spent like 75
80 000 just on my samples damn
you know what i'm saying just getting
everything together it's a hard business
to get into we always hear people do a
clothing line the shoe line is like it's
such a [ __ ] hard thing to break into
because there's just the big dogs the
detail
so you'll think joe moses put out a shoe
like
you were like but you see the details
and this [ __ ] like it's detailed like so
where do you sell these at on my own i
got a store okay so we got a store in
bellflower um
we sell them on the internet and we sell
them on our website we sell them in the
store at my shows and my concerts are
you trying to get them into like cheek
or
i would love to get them in chic i would
love to get them in bloomies i would
love zoomies um bloomingdale's i would
love to get them in in the big spots i
haven't reached that
or i don't know anybody that reached out
to me yet but i sell these shoes for 200
[ __ ]
that's a win
you know what i'm saying
oh yeah
backpacks
everything